what up fam do you love apple computers
but not quite sure which one is best for
you and then pop into ijustine's virtual
mac depot yeah look that's justine right
there she's got old max new max big macs
small max she's even got a mac for your
freaking dog man oh good boy looking for
a new iphone boom need some accessories
duh plus we now have the all new lineup
of 2020 max featuring apple's very own
m1 chip super cool dude so don't wait
come visit ijustine's virtual mac depot
today you'll be glad you did and so will
justine because she's very lonely
[Music]
hi thank you for coming into justine's
virtual mac depot i'll be right with you
[Music]
hi i'm justine how can i help you oh
adrian hi very nice to meet you i i'm
justine this is my mac depot welcome so
you currently don't have a computer
you do have an ipad you have an iphone
and imac is currently on your agenda
okay uh adrian i wish that we had an m1
imac that i could sell for you today now
we still do have intel max we have one
of the new imacs back here that has the
nano texture glass which is beautiful
but apple's kind of working on this
little two-year transition period where
they're transitioning all of their
current intel max to the m1 chip we
don't have any imacs with the m1 chip
here yet so you know check back later we
probably will be working on those
secretly in the back room somewhere but
i can't give you any information as to
when that's gonna be but if you are
looking for something stationary i think
this mac mini might just do the trick
now the problem though is
it doesn't come with a keyboard or a
mouse or a monitor but if you have those
already you can basically use anything
we've
they're sold separately
this is the least expensive mac in the
entire lineup right now so this is
starting at just 6.99 and you can
configure these up to 16 gigs of memory
and even with a 2 terabyte solid state
drive so you're going to be getting
three times faster cpu and 8 core gpu
for six times faster graphics there's
also an ethernet port we have hdmi 2.0
we have two usb c4 ports which are also
thunderbolt compatible and this is also
very
very interesting because this is also
compatible with the new pro display xdr
displays so you can get a full 6k
resolution if you hook this up to one of
those displays now
those displays are about six thousand
dollars so
at that point
you could probably buy eight and a half
mac minis so think about it you can
start a render farm i don't know maybe
that's something that you're into
you could also use either one of these
new laptops as a desktop machine you
just have to plug it into a monitor so
you can basically be using it as a
desktop we got dongles for that of
course uh they're sold separately but i
got them
but then you can just unplug it and take
it to the other room or if you are
someone who does leave the house
you can take it anywhere
i take mine to bed
that's it
so i do just want to mention that like
these three macs these are not like top
of the line computers these are more
entry-level macs but what's really
exciting is
we've been able we well i i don't
actually work for apple this is a mac
devo so we're kind of just like a little
you know
we just we're not affiliated but they
have put a lot of pro features into
these entry-level devices with this new
m1 chip and it's really
really exciting so normally i'm editing
on one of the highest end 16-inch
macbook pros and i'm editing a lot of 4k
footage a lot of 120 from the a7s3 and
this macbook pro it didn't even skip any
frames i
me i was impressed adrian i think you
would also be pretty impressed as well
the macbook air is pretty impressive i
mean this is a very small device it's
also fanless so it is completely silent
so if you do a lot of like conference
calls or zoom calls or whatever kind of
conference call type thing that you're
into there's no fans it is so quiet so
you'll never have to worry about that
fan noise and something else that's
really cool is i was editing some 4k
footage in final cut and it was seamless
and the fact that i'm editing silently
is very impressive i don't know if
you've ever used macbooks before they
can be a little loud with fans with the
cooling but because of the m1 chip it's
way more power efficient and that's how
they're able to get this fanless design
now if you need a little bit more power
though we've got this macbook pro
13-inch and this is very very
interesting because this is the macbook
that has the longest battery life of any
mac ever the other thing that's
impressive is being able to edit 8k
prores footage on this small tiny little
macbook and i adrian i'm not sure if
you're doing ak footage but if you are
i mean you probably
aren't going to be looking at this to be
your main editing machine
but knowing that you're able to do that
it's pretty cool huh so you're probably
torn because just looking at these two
side by side the specs are very similar
but with a pro it does have the fan so
it does consume a little bit more power
because it does have a larger battery
the screen is a little bit brighter and
it does have this touch bar so if you do
think that you're going to be doing more
processor intensive things a lot of
photo editing a lot of video i would
probably recommend the macbook pro i do
just want to remind you these are the
first three m1 devices that apple has
created there's going to be more in the
future that will be more powerful than
these so if you don't think that these
can handle the job of what you need to
get done on a daily basis then i would
either number one i would wait or they
have a ton of other computers in their
inventory that are still intel based
that will be supported for many years to
come so you don't have to worry you're
going to get an intel mac because you
need something more powerful that's okay
we're not going to fault you the one
thing i do want to note is the storage
options on some of these lower end
models is not a lot it's like 256 gigs
for me
that would be one single video and then
it's full but i don't really ever edit
any of my footage off of the system
drive i mostly use that for software you
can upgrade the storage up to two
terabytes but that's where things get
spendy if you're still interested i can
do some demos in the back just uh just
give me a second to set up
[Music]
so the first demo that i'd like to show
you is instant on i completely shut this
computer down it's off
now watch this is pretty cool
[Applause]
whoa did you also notice that that
little startup chime is back
for our first test let's open up final
cut and i will try to edit some 8k
footage and let's see how that works out
the thing that i've really loved a lot
is how quickly
this opens like the apps are
super snappy look how quick this opens
final cut we just open up a library
instant it's all it really is almost
instant this has some 8k footage already
in it i'm actually gonna i'm just gonna
select all of this i mean look how
quickly i'm editing i'm i'm moving all
of these 8k clips all around this is all
8k prores
just
just for the record
[Music]
get out a sharpie and color me impressed
now let me drop in some of my 8k prores
footage
oh wow look at that oh my god look at
that you guys i'm i'm impressed we shot
this on the red this is so freaking fast
okay let's let's get this colored up
[Music]
all right so that was some 8k red prores
converted footage now here's a raw clip
right from the sony a7 s3 this is shot
in 120
10 bit
oh my gosh look at this this is crazy
this is this is working so well
i'm not gonna lie i've definitely been
struggling with some of the a7 s3
footage when we've shot it in 120
on some of my intel max okay so i'm
going to slow this down by 50 percent
[Music]
this is running so well so we're we're
playing right now at better performance
so let's click better quality
and we're going to start this
from the beginning
[Music]
wow
this is
i'm pretty impressed
now let's drop in some drone footage
let's see what i've got
oh yeah look at that look at that look
at that look at that look at that epic
epic epic epic this is running very well
all right let's export it let's export
it let's take this let's take this bad
boy into compressor and see what you got
okay let's just export this full rest
see what happens just full thing
here we go we're sharing it the fans
have not even turned on yet
this is an ak timeline
like what the heck
here it is this is a full
8k video that just exported
oh my god does that look good
we'll see another demo okay
let's show you how quick things open up
lightroom
[Music]
this is loading in a bunch of my
files that i already have uploaded from
the cloud i mean this is crazy like we
can just
cruise through these and then if i want
to import some more let's uh let's do
that as well so here's some photos that
were shot on the sony a7r iv let's
review these for import
let's just add them all to the 63 photos
of the library why not let's just edit
this we'll edit
how about
that one
let's maybe just click and edit this in
photoshop because usually this takes
a little while to just sort of you know
pop over into photoshop from lightroom
so we'll see how how quick this is
[Music]
and
that was
surprisingly
also quite
quite quick yeah but here's my photo
that i edited in lightroom brought into
photoshop another demo that i'd like to
show you this is in affinity publisher
and this is
super
impressive i
could not believe
what i witnessed so we've got this
really cool vector image here now we're
going to zoom in
we're at 200 right now
looks cool
okay 300 400 500
all right things are looking good
everything looks
very nice and smooth
let's keep going shall we
we're going to zoom into this toy shop
we are now
2 400
okay 3 800 oh look at this suitcase oh
hold on a second we're going to keep
going oh there's a picture on the
suitcase let's see what's on the picture
oh look another town should we keep
zooming oh we are now inside
of the picture on the suitcase
look at this
look at we're
we're
so
i can't even read this number
how zoomed in we are we're like 136
million times zoomed into this you wanna
let's here we go
[Music]
another thing that's very exciting is
now on the m1 max we're able to open
iphone and ipad apps on your mac
pretty cool this is kitchen stories this
is an ipad an iphone app and now it's
running on my mac so this is going to
kind of open up a whole new world for
developers to start developing not only
just for ios or ipad os but they're able
to cross-develop so they'll be able to
work on your mac
let's play a game what's this whoa
you
are comrade ivan ivanovic
[Music]
this fan still hasn't turned on i
promise you if i even just open my 16
inch macbook pro the fan is gonna turn
on so now that you've seen a little demo
on the 13-inch macbook pro
let's do the same thing on the macbook
air and see how this one performs
[Music]
so the demo i'd like to show you on the
macbook air this is going to be a little
4k timeline and final cut this has some
prores footage ready to go look at this
[Music]
cool
cool okay now let me drop in some of my
4k content see what we can get also
we're just going to drop in that ak
piece of footage too and just see how
that handles it you know i mean we might
as well
i mean it's
this is a 4k timeline but this is still
handling this 8k
clip
like a champion
let's see what else what are the clips
i've got in here we've got some content
from the a7s3 this is all shot in 120
and i will say that sometimes using this
120 10 bit 422 footage just right
straight off the camera
does give my macbook pro 16 inch
stutters a little
and this let's remember this is a
macbook air okay
we are doing better performance right
now
so we'll slow this down to
let's do 25 percent
and do this also to 25
should i try opening the 8k timeline and
just see what happens
we might as well right
this is the this is the 8k the ak is
running
it's running
quite well
on here what the heck
look at this
let me just confirm with
let me confirm
you freaking look at this
look
you adrian do you see it michael gear
this is ak automatically
[Music]
we have a few frames dropped there but
there's two
that was two streams of ak
[Music]
[Applause]
let's set up the mac midi so i can give
you a demo of that
[Music]
we've now got our mac mini all set up
the cool thing about the mac mini is
that it does have a speaker built into
it and it's not like that impressive but
it does have one obviously as you can
see this is connected to the pro display
xdr and it is running
very
very beautifully so i just opened up the
8k library that we were using on both of
the other macs as well
and here we go
i mean are you surprised that it's
running
this one like this is
look how big i can make this
oh my gosh
wow
normally when i'm editing i don't edit
with a screen that's this large i'm
usually editing
with like a bunch of different screens
open i've got like
i've got my levels i've got all kinds of
stuff happening i've got all kinds of
things going on so having a bigger
monitor like this allows me to have all
of my different windows open and be able
to access a lot of different content
even quicker
wow wow
wow all right let's bring in some of my
content
into this timeline decided to drive over
the camera
i was like is this a good idea or is it
not a good idea it's probably not
oh my gosh and there i was i was like
whoa dude
we'll end it there yeah watch this watch
this watch this
oh yeah that's nice okay so there's a
little bit of frames dropping there so
we are in better performance again this
is an 8k timeline oh
just i just really you know i have a mac
pro and then i'm using a mac mini to
edit ak footage and i'm questioning
everything adrian
questioning it all oh
okay i probably should have turned the
audio off but
[Music]
so what's cool though about this mac
mini is this does have an hdmi output so
you really can use this as kind of like
an entertainment device you can hook
this up to a tv anything that is hdmi
you can use it
editing ak on the mac mini check gaming
on the mac mini check if you'd like i
can meet you up at the register i'm just
going to finish this level
very quickly i hope that i was able to
answer some of your questions today
about the new m1 max thank you so much
for coming into the mac depot i had so
much fun chatting with you but if you
have any further questions feel free to
leave them in the comments below but now
i gotta get back to work i've got a lot
of email
to take care of
[Applause]
okay i'm gonna get out of the tree
and then pop up
[Applause]
that wasn't true
you